[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday august 19th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor and we're back after a
short break courtesy of test and trace
on this week's show
the taliban have taken over afghanistan
we'll discuss the withdrawal and what it
means for joe biden i'll also hear from
a professor in kabul and a journalist
who witnessed the government's collapse
we'll then turn to china with the
spectator's own cindy yu who writes in
the magazine this week that the zeros
covered strategy put forward by the
government can't last so what's the
alternative and will people go along
with it
lea mckinstry says that brands are
co-opting poverty for profit what should
it mean
we'll speak to leo and the commentator
and writer grace blakely
and finally most people wanted more
space in lockdown when martin vanderwear
ditched his yorkshire home for a london
flat what was he thinking
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv then subscribe to our
youtube channel for free click the
button at the bottom of this video and
then tap the bell icon to make sure you
never miss an episode and while you're
there why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine too get 12 weeks of the
magazine for just 12 pounds and we'll
also give you a free 20 pound amazon
voucher completely free
that's free monster the spectator
delivered to your door and available
online for just 12 pounds along with the
amazon voucher just go to spectator dot
co dot uk forward slash tv offer to take
it up
now first
afghans desperate to escape taliban rule
have been trying to board evacuation
flights out of the country and videos of
the chaotic scenes have been seen across
the world
joe biden now insists this was always
the plan but how will the public see it
to discuss i'm joined by our deputy
editor freddie gray who writes this
week's politics column on the issue and
by ben page ceo of polling from ipsos
murray
freddie ben thank you for joining us
today on spectate tv and freddie first
usa biden has learnt a valuable lesson
from donald trump can you explain
well i i think that obviously biden is
getting a lot of political flack about
his decision to withdraw from
afghanistan and his insistence that it
was the right thing
to do and i think
that the immediate polls
i'm sure ben is about to join us will
tell us a bit more about that but i
think the immediate polls show that
there's a slight decline in his job
approval rating
but i think what biden has understood is
that
in
triggering the sort of media apoplexy
the kind of global media anger that he
has
uh in the last few days you can quite
often win over a lot of voters and i
don't want to get involved in the the
kind of morality of afghanistan and
those issues i want to just talk about
in terms of what biden's thinking
politically
i think that a lot of voters will be
thinking
the pompous journalist the sort of the
elite ruling class
that we don't like and it's not just
trumpist voters that think like that
it's it's a broad swathe of american
voters
they'll be thinking if they're so angry
about what biden's doing
and we generally support the idea of
withdrawing from afghanistan which they
do
i think it could end up being a net
positive
for joe biden
ben do you think he could be a net
positive how are those polling numbers
looking for well his his yeah his his
overall support levels dropped to the
lowest point in his presidency but it's
only down seven points from 53 to 46
approval so he's still doing rather
better than donald trump did at any
point but it's fair to say that his
ratings on handling the war are now the
lowest of any president
um during the last 20 years
but overall i think in in one sense i
agree with freddie because the america
for
most americans afghanistan is a far away
place about which they know very little
indeed and the majority of americans say
that they had to cut leave at some point
61
say that they we should that they were
right to proceed with the withdrawal on
the schedule that had been announced
and um although three-quarters want them
to intervene in in humanitarian terms
and to secure the airport and do all the
things that they're now doing um
only around half actually want to see
any sort of major military involvement
there again so i mean the american
public are a bit mixed but the balance
of opinion is that he's done the right
thing
so provided there aren't too many
casualties and there isn't another 9 11.
uh he's probably got away with it
and freddie when joe biden
spoke for the first time publicly since
the situation in afghanistan descended
as it did uh you saw a pitch that was
very much focused on the domestic
audience it appalled many in the
international community um but do you
think ultimately the white house is just
not particularly bothered what many of
biden's normal allies think he took a
long time to speak for example to your
other leaders
i think that's true i mean certainly
there were a lot of things biden has got
wrong i mean it took him ages to speak
he spent uh he apparently has not called
any other leaders
um he's generally looked as though he's
a little bit rash and unconcerned so it
does look as though his focus is
uniquely on the domestic situation
um and again i think
americans are very it's it's difficult
to try and explain the american psyche
because i think they kind of swing
between
uh historically they swing between being
far too eager to involve themselves in
world affairs and and too reluctant and
you saw after afghanistan uh sorry you
saw after vietnam
uh and saigon which everyone's been
talking about this week that american
people are very keen to sort of just
wash their hands of it
move on not exactly pretend it never
happened but just move on and look
forward and i think biden may be more in
tune with the american mood than a lot
of the media are and i do understand
what ben's saying that
there is a change in the polls at the
moment but it would be hardly it would
be pretty surprising if there wasn't
given the
barrage of negative headlines that's
going on i think yeah i mean i think
there's the key thing there's another
element here freddie which is i think
that americans don't like losing
regardless of the rights and wrongs of
it so i mean you know seeing seeing
people being lifted out of um embassies
and on the back of chinooks with raging
mobs outside and all that type of thing
is obviously that that isn't good but
you're right that america is withdrawing
for you know is for most americans they
want that they like to ask you know
america first
uh with donald trump and this in some
ways is an element of continuation of
that they i'd agree ben they don't like
losing they do also don't like never
winning which i think has been something
that's defined american policy for
for too many decades now
so ben what do you think could change
the possibility you mentioned a terror
attack back home but but also uh despite
the sweet talk from the taliban about uh
supporting women's rights to a degree
and we're starting to see or hear
reports at least that things might not
be as rosy as they suggest uh people
being tarred in kabul
women pleading to get out because they
say the taliban are after them so do you
think there are uh i suppose uh there's
a situation where uh chaotic scene in
afghanistan and the taliban uh bringing
in certain uh treatment of minorities
could change the american audience
reaction or do you think it really has
to be something more on home soil
i fear it would have to be more
domestically affecting america or
americans than actually what's
unfortunately going on in terms of human
rights and misogyny inside afghanistan
to be quite honest
uh so you know
let's wait and see but
i think for many americans they've been
there a long time they've lost thousands
of lives um
you know they haven't been able to
they've invested they've spent trillions
uh the current zeitgeist is to is to you
know is to pull back and of course focus
on china and russia and freddie how is
this landing within the democratic party
because ultimately with the democrats uh
you have seen some i think uh natural
supporters of joe biden horrified um
saying that this is out the trump
playbook uh so is this gonna damage him
internally even if not when it comes to
the mass audience i think it will
certainly divide them internally i mean
if you look at the sort of the
pro-israeli side
of of the democratic party they're
certainly anxious about the way
geopolitics is moving
in the region
uh however i also think that uh
people within the biden administration
spot the political opportunity that this
presents in the midterms and that's that
it splits
a slightly strange coalition that formed
in the trump years between a sort of
anti-right anti-war voter base on the
right
and a very hawkish
pro-interventionist strand within the
republican party
so
trump was successful through mike pompeo
his secretary of state he was successful
in in wooing the sort of people who
wanted to tear up the deal with iran who
wanted to rattle their sabers at iran
and north korea but he managed to not
get involved in a war at the same time
he was successful in appealing to people
who wanted to end the wars in
afghanistan and iraq but he never
actually really ended them
by going a little bit further by
actually ending this war in afghanistan
biden has sort of exposed a lot of kind
of semi-trumpist republicans as being
slightly fraudulent you've heard a lot
of people in recent days who just a year
ago were saying we've got to do whatever
it takes to end the endless wars now
criticizing biden for doing exactly that
he's he's exposed a risk in the
republican party and and that could
present some opportunities for democrats
and and finally it's just it's fair to
say that but the majority of both
democrat voters and republican voters
say they support ultimately leaving
afghanistan so
not perhaps in this way but that's what
they support
so ben do you think actually in a way
this could put the republicans in a
tough position
yeah absolutely because what are they
what are they now going to say he's now
done the thing that donald trump started
oh oh dear we don't like it i mean no so
i we don't we i don't think it's going
to give him you know a lot of he's not
going to lose sleep over the republican
position or or where they might now go
the only thing i'd add is is the
incompetence factor if because biden's
starting to look slightly incompetent on
other fronts if you look at inflation if
you look at the border
if there's a sort of general sense that
biden doesn't know what he's doing
uh and that he's making a mess of
everything that could start to hurt him
but but ben's absolutely right in terms
of the principles at the moment
uh the polls would suggest the public
are on his side
and his yes it's very different than
carter in you know in in 79 or iran or
hostages or anything like that at the
moment
and just finally i wanted to speak to
you very briefly about the special
relationship
uh freddie we have a situation where
today
um in the commons chamber you had
tory mps questioning the uk's reliance
on the us uh criticizing the fact that
ultimately once the u.s makes a decision
at the moment the uk seems to have to
fall into line even if they disagree
what do you think is happening with the
relationship between biden and boris uh
do you think that we are seeing a weaker
relationship than previously or is it
beyond that
i don't think there's a lot of
communication between the two
administrations on key points on
on what we've seen in parliament today i
i'd like to make a quite boringly
cynical point that i just think cameras
in parliament are a bad idea because we
saw this with hillary ben
and syria
and
the whole
frame media framing of every
parliamentary debate about foreign
affairs becomes about so the one big
speech
uh where some politician gets a sort of
wobbly lip says something emotional gets
a bit passionate maybe churchillian
and everybody says wasn't this
this defines this is what being a
parliamentarian is all about i don't
think it is i think being a
parliamentarian is about uh trying to
sort of decide what the british
government should do not
uh performing for social media
ben
um well i mean people whatever they say
they they like performative stuff going
on in parliament and it brings it to
life what we have seen is the public and
the british public are
much more critical of america than
clearly the american public and in fact
by some margin say that it was you know
we say it was wrong for the americans to
leave uh and i guess and reflecting to a
certain extent the way we feel beholden
to them but again the british public
still really value the special
relationship and all of the heritage
history and things that it symbolizes so
again i don't i don't think any the
price of fish hasn't really changed on
that yet it's just a statement of fact
really what has happened i've got to add
though i think it is i mean i don't want
to sound like a self-hating brit i'm not
but it's quite easy for us to
to talk about what america should do in
afghanistan we haven't really done
anything in afghanistan for 10 years
it's not really our problem anymore
would you not agree with that ben
i think i mean i think yes but we've
we've lost over we've we've lost over
450 lives in afghanistan we've had
troops there yes not as many as america
etc so i think you know again and the
british remain incredibly proud of our
armed forces they're you know they're
you can see that people want the
veterans to be treated fairly and there
is that same sort of general sense of
what was it you know why did we do that
what was it all for so the british want
to see
us getting involved in humanitarian aid
most people want to see
us taking lots of refugees only 18 of
people in britain despite often being
anti-immigrant generally only 18 say
they don't want any afghans coming here
at all and for everybody else the
majority say if they've worked with us
we need to we need to look after them
now and step in we aren't you know we
aren't particularly keen on more
military action it clearly hasn't worked
very much but you know we want britain
to be engaged and that's you know that's
the path the government will now have to
tread i guess in the you know and and i
think it's a really interesting
challenge with america withdrawing it's
a big reminder to europe
uh
with or without britain that it needs to
step up to the plate on some of this
stuff is america you know we need a
global policeman of some kind
potentially uh and if america is not
going to do as much of it what is europe
going to do and i think that's another
thing that will be raised from all of
this freddie ben thank you for joining
us
but how did it all go wrong in the first
place why did the afghan government fall
so easily to the taliban surprising
intelligence services across the world
i'm joined now by the freelance
journalist shelley kittleson who
reported from afghanistan for a month
during the collapse
shelley as i've mentioned you've been
reporting from afghanistan so can you
give us an idea of why in your view
the afghan forces collapsed so quickly
as far as what i saw initially quite a
few people were more confident at the
beginning of the month that i spent
there uh about potentially being able to
hold off the taliban being able to keep
at least the major cities
uh so forth and so on as the um
as the troops pulled out and
uh clearly uh air support was no longer
available in most places
more people started to become
a lot more afraid
when they took some of the border
crossings it became even worse
clearly
in early july we saw i mean for example
the islam khala border crossing with
iran was taken by the taliban and it
seemed as if the uh the iranians on the
other side were actually quite happy
about that
um which was also
a bit frightening for some of the people
there i obviously saw fighting when i
hear that the afghan troops did not
fight that's not true
um i
saw a lot of the afghan local police
were quite active and then actually
behind them on some of the front lines i
saw the afghan national army
some people
there in kandahar which is
the homeland of the taliban clearly that
is where
uh
omar is from
that's where they started it all in in
the early 1990s and then in 1996 took
control of the country clearly they had
control of most
of afghanistan until 2001 as as most of
your listeners will know
um
and yeah no i spoke to quite a few
people who actually said that they think
that this taliban will be worse it will
be better trained better funded better
organized
than before um and also they have
a very sophisticated sort of media
machine
it's interesting shelly what you say
about the almost the pr machine how this
is a different taliban because i think
one thing's been really striking uh
watching from the uk
is the various press conferences the use
of social media and as you say there's
effort to almost say to the
international stage uh we're not what
you think we are
we can work with you um but it seems to
me what you're saying there's heavy
skepticism on the ground that that is
really the case
in terms of yeah the the media um i
think that the taliban have learned
quite a lot from isis
i've worked quite extensively on
isis in iraq and syria
and clearly they had a very well oiled
propaganda machine as well
the
doha talks
were
were really useless most people say i
mean most people on the ground said that
two members of the peace negotiating
team for afghanistan for the afghan
government
that i spoke to both said that it was
absolutely useless that the taliban did
not want peace
uh the u.s wanted an excuse to get out
and that was a way to
get out while saying
that we're actually engaged in talks but
it did not seem that they were at all
interested and we've seen that in the
end that's what happened they pushed in
militarily until
uh
people ended up just handing over cities
to avoid mass destruction
so this isn't a negotiated
uh peaceful
ending
uh really i mean i don't think that you
can call it that
thank you shelley
and what about kabul today the taliban
is known for its historically awful
treatment of women and minorities will
this change there's certainly been a pr
mission to suggest so
professor faisal and from kabul
university is on the show now he's in
kabul where the internet isn't great so
he's called in to speak to us
fires thanks for coming on the show
what's it like where you are now
uh thank you so much for having me kabul
seems
different in many ways
security wise it is much more better
political wise it is a very different
kabul
days ago a week ago
and kabul there was a republican
government but now there is a return of
taliban
people
perspective wise it's very
different some people are happy because
of the security because of not having
any more bombs target killing and this
and that but many others they are
frightened because they think that
taliban might go extreme against them
taliban might return back to 1990s rule
of law and it will
somehow
contain the liberties of the people
especially the women group
youth different sports
and many other things but
so far
people are
getting
acquainted with the situation they are
getting out of their houses
shops are open bazaar is open texas or
on the road schools
universities some of the offices they're
open and uh you mentioned
there's some fear in
certain quarters about whether the
taliban's going to go back to the old
days but we've also been hearing through
press conferences um the taliban saying
that actually women will be able to
still receive education uh up to a
certain level at least do you think that
people believe that on the street um do
you get the sense that they they think
the talent uh are going to go through
with that
uh
that's the problem uh many people
they don't believe they doubt
taliban's promises
they think that taliban might get back
to their former
type of rule
to the extreme way
and they worry about
how they are going to
if the taliban turned their face back
but
taliban are very much consecutive said
they are very much
trying to prove that they are
truthful about their promises made for
example they are giving us examples of
media coverage
the
women
anchors they are all over different
televisions to lo
aryana
they are having those
lady
anchors talibans or even participating
in a political commentatory with them
women journalists they are out in the
streets of kabul
collecting their reporting and this and
that some women they have joined their
offices
today
we saw some of the pictures coming from
high schools where
women lecturers or teachers were there
they attended the schools
so taliban are also having
consecutive
media coverages from their
spokespersons convincing people that
the business should be the usual
people should not frighten
they have also uh given an amnesty
to the former warlords and people that
they fought against
currently in kabul dr abdullah he is
in his home he is meeting people and he
is
doing his business the same way mohammed
karzai is there many other
political
figures
mps parliamentarians they are all over
the country and then kabul they're
having their normal life so some of
these examples uh convince uh some of
the critiques and people
now
one of the things that's taken both the
uk and the us by surprise is how quickly
um i managed to ultimately take hold of
the majority of afghanistan and it's
been put down to various factors um in
terms of
soldiers not fighting or but also
perhaps a lack of resistance so i
wondered what you thought uh allowed um
the taliban to move in so quickly were
people welcoming it
uh i think
one way it is not quickly they are
fought
against
u.s and vision for 20 years
the resistance was
there for two decades
the takeover of kabul took
taliban two decades to come back to
kabul but
many
people they forget this part they only
think of the last days of the last
minutes of the war
there were miscalculations
misperceptions about the resistance from
government forces
the government forces were
morally they were not very much
empowered once the exit was happening
from biden
administration a very quick and hasty
one a second corruption in all
ranks of the
government especially in the military it
was devastating the third
incompetency much of the leadership
within the government and specifically
within the military was politicized
ethnicized
they were not
national leadership on the ground and
finally
once
there was
a defeat on the lower grade or on the
lower
battlefield for example on the district
level the demento effect happen and
the districts after districts fall and
then the provincial centers fall after
the provincial centers so overall the
come back of taliban to
kabul it was a 2-d resistance war and
harsh fight and then
within the speed up come back in last
minutes and last days and weeks it was
all the result of the 20 year of
corruption
mismanagement
not having national consensus and kabul
and competency and overall a dependency
of afghan government on nato and u.s
forces
thank you fires
and now to china
the country officially at least is
reporting just 2 000 cases a day but
state media says it's the most serious
way of the pandemic so far
in this week's magazine cindy writes
that the country's zero covert approach
can't last she joins me now
cindy thank you for coming on can you
explain china's strategy and has how
it's going
yeah katie if if anything it's probably
going a bit too well in that they've
closed down the borders so much that
they haven't really had much covert at
all since getting on top of the first
wave which of course came from china so
the border policy at the moment in some
places you have to do up to four weeks
of hotel quarantine and that's with a
hotel where you can't even open a window
let alone go for a walk so it's proper
quarantined stuff which really just
effectively closes the border but now
they've got another wave because
obviously things do get passed they've
only got about 2 000 active cases in the
entire country but it's completely
panicked the government's rather central
or local
and it really raises the question about
how well the vaccination program is
going which is you know going relatively
slowly compared to um the uk in terms of
per capita so what i mean by that is
china's a huge country it's got 1.4
billion people
to have anything like the vaccine
coverage that the uk has it's going to
need nearly 3 billion vaccines so it's a
lot it's a big task but at the moment
they've only got around 57 fully
vaccinated people we also know that the
chinese vaccines are not as effective as
the western vaccines you know so all of
this raises the question if you don't
have internal immunity when are you
going to open those borders up and if
you don't order open those borders up
when are you going to stop
start accepting that you're going to
have to live with covid because
coronavirus is not going anywhere
now as you say it had been going fairly
well from china since that initial
outbreak and you have an interesting
example in your piece where you talk
about your grandmother who went back to
china and had a big birthday bash which
you had to watch from i think was that
in january when the uk was locked down
yeah casey i mean that was at the point
at which we were fantasizing about even
outdoor dining then i get these pictures
on my wechat from my family in china and
they're just hugging laughing drinking a
hundred people in this restaurant um
celebrating my grandmother's 80th
birthday and i was incredibly jealous
because as you say as i say you know we
couldn't even see people at that point
in our third lockdown of england um but
since then covert has gone back you know
actually
in the city that my grandmother lives in
nanjing that's where it started this
time around um and numerous officials
have been sacked or punished in various
ways um and china's really having to
think about at this crossroads
how long we're going to stick with zero
kovid what are we going to do about herd
immunity and what are we going to do in
the next few years
now you mentioned the vaccination
program you've written previously about
the various china vaccines um so it's
the issue here that actually when we
look at the various vaccines being used
across the world the china vaccines are
ultimately just not as successful in uh
providing immunity
yeah that's right i mean china
domestically now has five different
vaccines the ones that we know about
quite a lot over here are synovac and
sino-farm
but that's not the only vaccines are
available in china but most of those
vaccines use the old method of
inactivated viruses which is the
traditional way of you know killing a
virus and then injecting that to trigger
an immune system response is not as
advanced as mrna it's not as effective
or
prone to uh to to success when it comes
to variants and so you know even with
full vaccination we're probably gonna
look at maybe sixty percent seventy
percent efficacy of protection whereas
with the pfizer you're getting over
ninety percent obviously astrazeneca is
somewhere in between that as well um and
china hasn't allowed hasn't regulated
hasn't approved any western vaccines at
the moment they're looking at pfizers
they're looking at making pfizer the
booster jab as well as even the chinese
are thinking about doing that but they
don't have enough they've only got 100
million which is a drop in the ocean
compared to the population of the
country
and what about vaccine hesitancy is that
an issue when it comes to the chinese
population and the fact that as you say
in the piece uh you have some uh parts
of china such as beijing where there
seems to be very high vaccine uptake but
that's perhaps because they've been
offered more vaccine and other parts of
china where it doesn't really compare in
the slightest
yeah i mean okay you won't be surprised
to know that there's not much public
opinion polling in china so it's hard to
say this you know with a scientific
basis yougov does claim that two fifths
uh in a poll that they did that
two-fifths of chinese are vaccine
hesitant compared to only one-fifths of
of brits and three-fifths of french so
it's somewhere in between that but for
my conversations with chinese people and
looking on social media there's a fair
amount of hesitancy just because with
the covert situation in control they
don't think of vaccination as the way
out in the same way that we thought that
in january and february you know we were
in lockdown unless we got vaccinated
life couldn't possibly go back to normal
china hasn't been doing that as you
mentioned my grandmother's birthday
party happened without vaccinations so
in that kind of situation a lot of
people are saying well what's the point
actually other people can get vaccinated
before i do um so why should i have to
get vaccinated um and in places like
beijing it's very interesting actually
the city has been cocooned throughout
the
from the beginning of the pandemic
because that's where chinese leaders are
and a lot of them are in their late 60s
early 70s so they're in a high risk
category and the beijingers have been
you know whether it's quarantine or
vaccinations they've been throughout all
of this the most shielded in order to
protect those leaders and in other parts
of the country the coverage is just not
really enough and these are provinces of
tens of millions of people where the
vaccine coverage is only about a fifth
um complete vaccination so you know
you've got huge pockets where you just
are not immune at all
so china is looking for a zero-covered
policy and and never has much in common
australia and new zealand but
there's also an interesting comparison
when it comes to australia because
you mentioned the piece um
a figure in china who said that perhaps
the country would have to learn to live
with covert and we've also uh had uh
one politician in australia saying that
i'm getting a very mixed response so how
does the idea of living with covid uh
how is that seen
it goes down very badly um the july 19
reopening in the uk in england was
reported on in china surrendering to the
virus that the uk has recklessly
surrendered now and it's just given up
basically which of course is not what
happened here we know that um but so
that's why when this epidemiologist john
wong hong who's been quite leading
throughout the pandemic in and quite
vocal about what he thinks is the best
way forward when he said actually a lot
of scientists think that we're going to
have to co-exist with the covert are we
going to have to think about how we're
going to live with it
you know you have social media people
saying what is he saying he's a traitor
he wants us all to die getting very very
hysterical and absolute dog piling on on
this man on social media and since then
some of those people have dug up some
allegations that this epidemiologist
plagiarized his doctoral dissertation
from decades ago and he's now under
investigation at his by his university
in order to look into these allegations
on the other hand you have had people
who've said you know leave him alone let
him talk i mean clearly this is the way
forward if you look at the west so
there's definitely a debate going on
online as much as there can be a debate
in china um but a lot of people do think
that living with covert is a reckless
way forward
and cindy i suppose just finally
do you think this issue is going to come
to a head if uh ultimately uh people in
china face ongoing restrictions looking
across the world and maybe saying it's
reckless or is giving in um but just as
we've seen in obviously countries like
australia different but
i think growing uh where these countries
had been being praised early on is
almost like a turning of the tables so
what do you think of the crunch points
coming up
yeah exactly it's just not sustainable
to have a zero covered policy
in the very first part of the race it
looks like you're doing better you've
got much lower death rate um you're able
to open up a little bit
faster because you've closed down the
borders so absolutely compared to the
english approach which has been you know
in out and out you know groundhog day
when it comes to lockdowns and
restrictions coming back and all this
sort of thing is quite mentally tiring
but now that we focus on vaccinations
scientists here don't think that we're
going to have to lock down ever again
whereas i'm not hearing from australia
china or new zealand when they're going
to open their border and in the china
case next year is a really important
year for the chinese communist party in
february they've got the winter olympics
so it's a really important pr moment for
the for the government and then in
october presidency celebrates his first
10 years in power this was the year that
he was meant to be stepping down but of
course he's abolished term limit so this
is his first decade and that's an
incredibly politically sensitive time so
i don't think china is going to open up
its borders next year at all so that's
why i conclude my piece by saying i
don't think i'm going to see my
grandmother before her 82nd birthday at
this rate and talking to other people
who work in the china field they think
similarly that we're not going to no
one's going to be able to get back into
china without these ridiculous
quarantines for the next few years
thanks cindy now back home what does
poverty mean in this week's magazine
liam mckenzie writes that the term is
overused and co-opted by corporate
brands
leo joins me now along with grace
blakely the commentator
leo grace thank you for coming on today
um leo you write in your piece uh how
the term poverty has taken on a new
meaning can you explain
well poverty is a genuine
problem in britain on a worrying scale
and that has been exacerbated by the
pandemic but i do think that uh
that my article shows how
poverty is both being
exaggerated uh by pressure groups the
incidence of poverty is being
exaggerated by new definitions used by
pressure groups in order to
grab headlines and
gain interest for their work and also by
big corporations that want to indulge in
a bit of virtue signaling by associating
themselves with a fight for social
justice and uh in both cases i don't
feel that there's a genuine concern for
addressing real poverty in britain which
of course exists as i say on a worrying
scale i live down and near margate and
of course i see poverty all the time
around me but i i think the incidence of
poverty is being exaggerated for
political lands and for corporate ends
and uh
there's so many examples of that one of
the most absurd is trans transport
poverty which the royal automobile club
the rac
defines
if you spend more than 10 percent of
your income on transport you are in
relative transport poverty which is
absurd of course because rich people did
by definition spend more of their income
on
transport whether it's on international
travel or gas guzzling cars or more on
petrol or more expensive cars
or first-class train travel and you
render the ridiculous situation that
those who defined in the biggest
transport property are the very richest
the people who own maybe
rolls-royce and bentley's actually the
rolls-royce in the driveway is a badge
of poverty which shows how distorted
statistics can get when you go down this
road
grace do you think the term poverty can
be distorted when it's used by
corporations um the example leah just
gave is one where it's not so much
whether or not you can afford something
compared to your direct earnings says
the percentage of your earnings you're
having to spend on it which is a bit
further away from what i think people
would originally think
i mean i i have really actually
interestingly enough mixed feelings
about uh about this and i think my
feelings are really summed up by the
cartoon that's used at the top of leo's
piece which is on the one hand a kind of
indictment of consumerism and the
lengths to which brands will go to
convince us that we simply must have
things um often things that we don't
need in order to kind of be considered
uh legitimate human beings or to feel
good about ourselves but is on the other
hand a vilification of working class
people who do need those things and i
think there's something here about about
inequality and the impact that it has on
our perceptions and also the way that we
feel about ourselves and the way that we
kind of um
you know ascribe value to people and i
think on the one hand there's this issue
of perception it's you know very
difficult for people like us perhaps who
um aren't struggling on a daily basis to
buy the things that we need to imagine
what it would be like to live on you
know 257 pounds a month for example
which is the amount of universal credit
you get as a single person under 25. i
mean just the strain of having to
calculate firstly in the context of a
housing crisis after rent which is
something that's really non-negotiable
utilities food etc um you know just
being able to think can i have a coffee
for example or will that mean that i
won't be able to buy food for myself and
my kids which is genuinely an issue that
a lot of people face
and i think on the other hand there's
this issue that in a highly unequal
society where you have people at the
very very top able to buy all these
things that brands are trying to
convince us that we need and others not
you have this sense that um you know
really in order to be considered a kind
of a human being
of any dignity or worth you have to be
able to buy a pair of trainers or buy
this particular thing that will make
people look at you in a certain way and
certainly i think for people who are in
jobs where perhaps they're either
ignored or treated basically with
contempt a lot of the time there is this
sense that maybe by buying things they
can become
you know worth something and all of
those issues are complicated and they're
linked to
the way that we conceive of ourselves
and the way that we conceive of each
other in a society that is marked by
quite extreme levels of inequality at
this point
leo's interesting there grace talking
about inequality uh and obviously
inequality and poverty are linked um but
when we're talking about uh being able
to purchase things from certain shops uh
particularly uh when we're looking at
some of these transport examples you
could say it's more inequality than
poverty so what do you define poverty as
well
i mean cause that opens a huge debate on
poverty poverty absolute poverty which
is uh destitution and the struggling
for day-to-day
goods of life and relative poverty i
mean i always think that in in monaco
there must be people in relative poverty
or millionaires because they don't have
that they don't have a yacht or a
billionaire status so it can be terribly
distorted and i think that's one of the
thrusts of my article that uh how
distorted the figures can be and grace
talked about people struck struggling
but of course one of the uh points about
ever ever widening the definition of
poverty and talking about so many
endless new
categories of poverty like we there's
even talk of smartphone poverty if
people don't have a smartphone there per
a holiday poverty uh bad poverty
furniture poverty
and uh if you widen the definition of
victimhood so much it becomes
meaningless i mean one one of the
statistics that i mentioned i think i
mentioned in my article was from a
charity that says
over 50 percent of londoners suffer from
hygiene poverty which means that they
can't afford basic hygiene products and
that just strikes me as an absurd
uh
[Music]
absurd assertion to make that more than
half of people in london one of the
richest cities in the world are actually
struggling to afford basic hygiene
products it doesn't make any sense
and then again you know this this speaks
to this question of inequality because
london is a very very wealthy city but
it is also one it is but are you
seriously saying very very high levels
of poverty sorry are you seriously
suggesting that more than half of people
in london can't afford basic hygiene
products
i wouldn't be surprised if more than
half of people in london have to think
very very seriously about the decisions
we all have to think seriously
well it doesn't matter because it does
it mean you know we know from
psychological studies that just living
in poverty puts an immense amount of
strain there is a cognitive load
associated with thinking right i have
this amount of income to spend each week
if i go to the end of that that bit of
income i will not be able to buy certain
things that i need there's a um
an example that's used that's you know a
memorable way of describing what it's
like to live in poverty or on the edge
of poverty is do you live in dread of
getting a toothache or your car breaking
down because you just don't have the
amount of money that you would need at
disposable to be able to cover those
costs or
you know you would have to go to maybe
you know your bank or even to a kind of
payday loan company and pay extortion
amounts of interest just to be able to
cover those unexpected costs i would not
be surprised if there was a very very
large proportion of people in our
society living under those conditions
but more than half of london is one of
the richest cities in the world it
doesn't really make sense and
i mean another claim made by a different
research group was that thousands of
people in the uk have little or nothing
to wear when they were talking about
clothing poverty and again that doesn't
really match reality i mean
the cost of clothing has come down by
more than half over the last 30 years we
actually live in an age where clothes
are incredibly cheap and to pretend that
most british people are living in death
or
thousands of british people are an
absolute destitution where they have
little or nothing to wear it actually
undermines the real fight against
poverty by creating disillusion and
cynicism by with these exaggerated
claims
i think there is there is a genuine
question here about kind of brand virtue
signaling um which you know and i i do
think that often brands will take
advantage of
of these kinds of campaigns to be able
to kind of you know whether it's accrue
some level of um
you know respect amongst their their
consumers or just to kind of sell more
stuff that is definitely an issue i mean
when you talk about kind of transport
and clothing that's potentially a
question here but there's also something
about
why campaigners often not just brands
feel the need to couch these questions
in these terms you know when you go in
the news no one wants to hear about
poverty or inequality no one wants to
hear about these big you know basically
features of the way that we organize our
economy and uh you know the the
solutions being quite transformative um
economic policies that would reduce
inequality they feel like very big
issues that would be very very difficult
to fix whereas if you're a brand or you
know a campaigner and you go on the tv
to talk about period poverty um then it
feels like something okay i can
understand what that is and also i might
be willing to
um you know donate or to to maybe
condone legislation that would deal with
this one specific area so there's a
question of comms and communications
here that i certainly think is important
but it's also a question of you know the
challenges that we face in our society
as you mentioned poverty is so high this
feels so big
that it's hard to get your head around
it um and i think that actually requires
us not to talk less about poverty and
inequality but to speak more about those
issues and what we can really do at the
macro level to speak to the fact that
there are so many people in this country
who literally cannot afford at the end
of the week to make ends meet grace when
we're i suppose leaning to uh leo's
point about uh the way poverty is banded
around by some corporations these days
and we're talking about smartphone
poverty holiday poverty do you think
that although uh talking about it more
widely is a good thing that does make it
harder to actually uh address the people
really in need those in absolute poverty
if we do overuse the term
i think certainly when it comes from
brands people have you know a legitimate
reason for being skeptical but i also
think often when we have these
discussions i mean i remember when we
saw this um with regards to food banks
there was a lot of discussion on twitter
as to oh seriously who could actually
not be able to afford food i've put
together this meal of like one egg and a
piece of toast and it cost me 15 p there
is this sense i think of a kind of
distinction between and this has always
been the case in the uk all the way back
to the poor laws the deserving and the
undeserving poor um it's it's the kind
of thing you know where you go along the
street and you see a homeless person and
you think i'm not gonna give them money
because they're just gonna spend it on
drugs but your perception of that
changes when you realize that um you
know a third of young people leaving
social care become homeless in the first
two years after leaving care and there
are obviously the the these set of
issues around
mental health physical health abuse
poverty substance abuse that mean that
these people are actually you know not
undeserving poor but actually living
with a whole set of very very difficult
issues that make their lives much much
harder and that's you know an extreme
case but the point does extend i think
to poverty in general which is that it
is just hard to be poor and it's
particularly hard to be poor in a
consumeristic society like ours that
teaches people that if you can afford a
smartphone if you can afford a new pair
of trainers if you can afford a range
rover you are somewhat higher up in the
social hierarchy than someone who can't
finally leo i mean we're talking about
and you make the argument that a lot of
this banding around at the time makes it
much harder to address real poverty so
what do you think the focus should be in
doing that
well i i think two things
should happen i think that we should be
much more rigorous about the definition
of poverty and not and not eat and
challenge pressure groups and
corporations that actually issue these
bogus statistics like the claim that 43
percent of parents of primary school
children go without basic hygiene
products because they can't afford it i
mean about
four bars of soap from aldi i found cost
59p i mean
is it seriously suggested that
over 40 percent of
families in britain can't afford 59p for
four bars of soap so i think we've got
to be far more rigorous about the
definition of poverty and also we should
concentrate resources
much more
which was what the last coalition
government was trying to do was
concentrate resources much more on real
need and if we fall for this
argument that
half of londoners are in part in hygiene
poverty and that 80 of us on transport
poverty will get absolutely nowhere
you'll just have to spray money around
like
graffiti on such an epic scale that
you'll just have colossal waste and
you'll worsen dependency and you'll
heighten expectations i think what i'm
really calling for in this article is
much more rigor
much more skepticism and much more
challenged for the poverty campaigns who
make these wild claims
i think we just need to treat people
with a basic amount of respect and
dignity and
really try and put ourselves in the
shoes of someone who is living off a few
hundred pounds a month and imagine the
toll of being forced to make the choices
that they are forced to make and rather
actually i agree than saying oh let's
tackle this bit of poverty or that bit
of poverty and have a campaign and have
a brand sponsoring it let's actually say
not just spraying money around but think
about the very structure of our society
think about the problem of precarious
work of low wages of the immense housing
crisis that we have in this country and
actually say we need coordinated
top-down um and uh expansive political
action to tackle these challenges that
make so many people's lives so hard in
ways that most of us can't is that a
call for a massive expansion in the
welfare state
more than a call for expansion the
welfare state it's it's a call for the
kind of democratization of ownership of
resources in our society we need to
rebuild our social housing system we
need to uh you know remove anti-union
legislation that makes it hard for
working people to be able to organize to
demand higher wages we need not just
kind of tinkering around the edges a
little bit more tax there a bit more
spending there we need a structural
transformation of the way our society
works
i'm all in favor of a bit of tinkering
around the edge
thank you leo thank you grace
thank you
finally
would you give up eighty percent of the
space in your house
martin van der waale the spectator's
business editor did this when he moved
from yorkshire to london
going against the grain
what was he thinking and how is it
turning out
he joins me now
martin thanks for coming on today
um
ultimately we've heard for a long time
now how lots of people are fed up of
lockdown in cities have decided they
want to move to the countryside to have
more fresh air take advantage of working
from home but you've done the opposite
yes with with great pleasure um thank
you for inviting me um yeah so
you're quite right there was a sort of
cliche of conversation wasn't there all
through the lockdown phases where
estate agents banging on about how you
know fulham is buying wiltshire and all
that sort of nonsense
but it was really true a lot of people i
think felt
constrained by
their life in the cities and the big
towns
uh wanted more space out in the house
and outside and they wanted to as nature
flourished during lockdown people wanted
to go and enjoy nature well i've had the
great good fortune of living for 32
years in a
in a very nice house in north yorkshire
country house on the edge of a small
market town
so i i had all of that
but inside me i had this kind of urban
burlington bertie you know
uh boulevardier
trying to break out and
[Music]
it had been in my mind for quite a while
but the
the long lockdowns
brought that into focus and i thought
i just need to get on with this really i
know it's what i want to do why do i
want to do it well
when i was young
in my 20s early 30s
i lived not only in london but in a
series of foreign cities i lived in
brussels tokyo hong kong
and i really enjoyed
exploring
the cities that i lived in
making discoveries making new friends
and acquaintances all the time
um and so i just wanted some more of
that really i've had
30 years of lovely
rural small town life i'm ready to get
get back in the thick of it it's as
simple as that
and you mentioned in your piece uh that
you traded
your well-regarded you know listed
housing the auction out for london so
could you talk us through the square
footage trade you've made
well do you think that's a bit vulgar i
don't know
um anyway anyway
you know i suppose 5 000 square feet
isn't that big a country house but
that's roughly what i had um
uh it was quite a lot for a bachelor but
anyway it fitted me like an old overcoat
um in particular it because it was
actually a converted school
house um in an unusual position looking
across
uh my neighbor's stately parkland it's
not my parkland it's his but anyway i
had a nice view
so my house
because it was a schoolhouse it had a
very large room that had been the school
room which became the drawing room so
actually the flat i bought in london
would fit into the one room of the of
the old house more or less uh so that
really is quite a startling maneuver so
i've downsized by by roughly four fifths
from from 5000 square feet to 800 and
something how do i feel i don't i feel
absolutely fine about it one of the
things that was shifting in me was i
thought actually living in
small efficient nicely kitted out spaces
is just as good as living in
you know
large spacious accommodation that's what
i wanted to do in a previous phase now i
find i i i'm very happy in the kind of
efficient living pod but in a very very
interesting district of london
yes you're in seven dollars now can you
um what are you enjoying most about your
new london lifestyle
well so seven dollars is the enclave
between soho and
the
mainstream sort of piazza area of covent
garden
it is
a set of seven
mostly cobbled streets going off a
circular like a french class with a
monument in the middle the dial monument
and it has an ambience all of its own it
has very little vehicle traffic at the
moment
for this summer and probably for next
summer too i imagine it's almost
entirely turned over to street cafes
which was a bit controversial as you
know some residents of central london
are up in arms that their streets have
been turned into cafes
it came as a slight surprise to me that
that was happening because the camden
council
sent us a message saying they were
taking all the residents parking spaces
away
to replace them with uh
benches and and
tables and anyone who already had a
residence parking permit was enraged but
as it happened i hadn't got around to
applying for one so i wasn't so bothered
and now it's happened
it's rather delightful it's just a
little hubbub of
noise of people having a happy happy
hour cocktail
outside the window and it's completely
inoffensive
and
couldn't be nicer really it's theater
land i'm next door to a theater i'm
three doors down from another theater
and the theaters are slowly opening up
again there are hundreds of
interesting cafes and restaurants to
still to be discovered
um so it's it's great really and i can
walk to anywhere i'd like to be in
central london so it's a bold move i
mean it really is central central urban
living uh compared to
my life of the previous 30-something
years but so far so good i'm so far very
very very pleased with it yeah
now you're joining us from yorkshire
today um so you you have gone back um
what do your friends uh back there make
of it uh are they slightly envious are
they looking for weekend
well they all i mean the fact is i've
kept a small
uh
flat here as well and i have a
whole set of obligations up here so i
have to be here some of the time and i
still
very much enjoy being here and it's
refreshing to go to london and then to
come back
up here but most of my town i mean it's
a it's a small town of 2000 people we
all know each other quite well and they
all think i've left permanently so if i
after this call if i wander down to the
shops about you know 200 yards away i
will bump into half a dozen neighbors
who'll say oh just back for a short
visit are you martin and i have to say
no no no i haven't left really you know
i'm doing both at once
i have to keep explaining that but but
having both is nice yeah
and finally and for those watching this
thinking perhaps
i've got the wrong way around and maybe
i should be heading from the countryside
to the city and what's your advice to
them about making the transition
well i think it's perfectly sensible
if you're in your
you know middle decades and particularly
if you've got family and children and i
can see all the reasons why you
certainly wouldn't want to live in
complete sort of urban environment that
i've chosen
but
a bit later on in life
when you're free of you know children
being at home and you can make as many
choices as you like
then there's just such a lot to do
you know culturally socially
in the center of a big city and of
course there are green spaces i mean i'd
only have to walk i don't know seven ten
minutes i'm in st james's park on my way
to the spectator house and so on it's
it's not um it's not manhattan you know
it's london um so
i think as a choice for people who are
in the
the later stage of life i'm in my mid
60s i think i think it's a terrific
choice to make if you're younger you've
got a different set of priorities i can
quite see that and perhaps that's your
position katie i don't know where you
live um
but but um
i'm clinging on to the city for now
until
the bills get too bad
uh
but i one thing i wouldn't want to do if
i was in you know full weekly working
life i'm very much in favor of people
going back to the office
what i wouldn't recommend to people is
to take on a longer commuter journey
just to get out and get more fresh air
where you live do you know what i mean i
mean the idea of being able to walk to
work or bicycle to work
is a great thing in in the modern age
and uh
long inefficient you know towson late
commuter trains and so on are pretty
horrible prospects so i definitely avoid
that
martin thank you for joining us
and that's it for this week if you
enjoyed this episode don't forget to
subscribe to the spectators youtube
channel so you never miss an episode
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of this video and the bell icon
to make sure you never miss one
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you